[Music]
wow that back wall is hideous what a
mess you got two seconds please yes and
what's with the uh the swamp Decor whose
idea was that um mine and my husband's
to eat in a
swamp for children or for adults for
both for both for
both
o That's not words
me all right here we go okay thank you
all right what the hell is that he with
the oysters cortell oysters cortell so I
suppose you go like
that wow there
dread o is named after the owner I
certainly wouldn't put my name on that I
wouldn't even put my enemy's name on
that take it for you okay thank you
that's depressing is
it
no just terrible
oysters cortell I don't know what to say
about that I eat them myself I think
they're delicious absolutely delicious n
what did you say oysters cortell just
ain't
working this is killing me not to know
what he's
saying this is the fried chicken steak
right correct thank you you're
welcome Bland as anything no seasoning
no care look at that
Candace what the hell is that it looked
like it's just had a giraff tongue cut
out and deep fat fried people complain
that the quality of the food here is
horrible unbelievable Daryl's not
listening to the feedback that he gets
and he's going to do what he wants to
do Daryl yep he said that it looks like
somebody cut out a giraffe's tongue
battering Friday I'm not going to agree
with that it didn't look that way to me
I mean that's what normally goes out
it's a good product so it look like we
cut out a giraffe's
Tong wow wow wow Jesus thanks
[Music]
D doesn't look
fantastic it tastes delicious who made
that emal it makes it I'm just so happy
that Chef Ram he likes the bread pudding
it feels great to end on a good Noe love
the bread pudding you like the bread
pudding there we go loved it I took full
responsibility for bread pudding that is
all me Daryl doesn't really have
influence on that thank God thank God he
likes some I did I'll take that any
day hello hello chef and this is Daryl
the owner yes chef introduce me to your
uh Brigade Chef em Marcos em good to see
you buddy likewise Jason Jason good to
see you there's a lot of things that
that need change and and you know Daryl
is he's one of them can I talk about
lunch yes my go what a disaster the food
is below
standard why wouldn't you buy fresh
shrimp I simply don't have the time to
go to the
market excuse me where are we're in New
Orleans come on big boy chicken fried
steak
disaster what cut of meat was that not a
very good cut no are you proud to serve
that food no sir was that the same
quality of steak that we're using years
ago no sir then why have you changed the
standard no it's it's up to Daryl is
that a Cutting Corner method to save
money Chef everything is [__] to you but
we had diners eating all lunch full
dining room well and nothing's sent back
do you honestly think just because they
don't send it back that your food is
[__]
amazing that's good enough for you to
continue now you can't be that [__]
stupid point taken if they want to be
that stupid you've got no
chance
oh wow it looks
dull that's not
right smells is that
fresh um can you ask him how old the
chicken is
please W that was
nasty how old is the chicken I don't
know when did we get it uh I don't know
we took it out of the freezer yesterday
14 years old we took it out of the
freezer
yesterday it's frozen it is not fresh
cuz we can't afford to keep fresh meat
here all the time because we don't serve
that much if he wants to donate money so
I can make it fresh no problem but
otherwise
tough they're not open for lunch but so
far what I've just experienced they
shouldn't be open for dinner either he
took out the freezer yesterday and
doesn't remember when the delivery
was
excuse me oh dear excuse
me I didn't think it was that
bad under the tables it's littered with
a
gum Colleen yes look at that it's
everywhere absolutely disgusting how
lazy some people can
be let's go on a Gumball
Rally oh oh God under there look the
size of the gum under that one oh look
at that one at the end in the corner oh
my God look at that one there when was
the last time the tables were cleaned
not ever that I've known of underneath
they've never been cleaned underneath no
oh my God 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 7 8 9
10 18 19 20 bits of gum every freaking
table has gum underneath of it has gum
underneath we ready to get out of the
business
no don't say
[Music]
that come on stop crying throw up
you
[Music]
you uh Jim Jeff coming I'm really
nervous oh dear dear oh dear oh dear I'm
afraid of what Chef Ry has to say
honestly
you seem like nice guys but that was
painful the general feel of the place is
disgusting I can tell how much you don't
care you just stand there with your foot
on the booth can you get your dirty feet
off your own
booths have a look at
this every table is littered with stale
disgusting
gum we just we never looked underneath
the table didn't have the time busy for
lunch open 7 days a week week not the
meatball sandwich disgusting the chicken
was turning and then the Colossal Kate
with crap were they canned mushrooms on
top yeah canned olives mhm soggy and
tasteless where's the pride I don't know
come on guys it's like a joke find a
pulse and get real before we open for
dinner tonight would you mind wiping the
Lampshades and can somebody get under
the tables and get rid of that gum yeah
I'm going for lunch I'll see you later
starving Capri classic Italian what a
joke he said our food
sucked and
uh that our restaurant is really
filthy think it was that
[Music]
bad hey your vinegrette is too vinegary
okay you know what is wrong with it
because uh we've been running this food
for many years Martine you heard me
right I'm just letting you guys know
what he's saying
okay than you this is going to be the
seafood crepe I'm going to set that in
front of you here it looks like a pie
basically they take the dish they line
it with the with the Crepes they fill it
with the items fold it back and then
they bake it they're not like your
typical French crepe but why would you
call it a crepe if it's not rain
crepe I think when the seafood crepe
comes out it just looks like a slurpy
mess of
black can I have a word with your uh big
brother is he here or not he is
unfortunately not he will be here for
dinner service tonight okay all right
enjoy thank
you
okay
oh that is hideous it's it's it's hot in
Parts like in the middle but on the side
there Stone Cold
[Music]
want me to take it is the oven not
working no the oven's working fine can't
serve this [__] and expect customers
don't flood through the door I
understand how long's he been here the
Martin too long you're not wrong there
Martin lost his Mojo around here many
years ago if you got someone who doesn't
care about the food they're putting out
what do you
have Martin he said it's hot in the
middle it's cold on the sides he doesn't
like
it
thank you oh [__] how long's that been
under the grill cuz it looks like it's
been overcooked it's piping hot is he
microwaving that I don't know girl yes
when normally something's that piping
hot like that it always tells you that
it's been microwaved can you just check
with the chef okay I'll check listen
thank
you okay Martin the Kisha is warmed in
the oven yeah hasn't seen the microwave
no
[Music]
okay shf um kich no microwave I asked
him if he put it in he said no hold on
I'm convinced this has been microwaved
look at it it's congealed it's just like
a a rubber Puck sometimes if he gets a
little backed up I I've seen him do it
before backed up this is
ridiculous and let's go and uh meet
Martin please it's a food issue right
now it starts from the kitchen if we had
somebody in here who cared about the
food we'd be so much better than we are
now I want you to meet jef ham come
around
please you're the head chef and
everything I ate for lunch you cooked
yes sir lunch was a
disaster the keyin was rancid where did
you heat that up was that in the
microwave I no I disagree
okay we start on the microwave and then
uh we get on the oven yes so it did go
in the microwave that is right yes but
you just told me it wasn't in the
microwave why do you want to lie to me
do do you want me to lie to you no I'm
not lying to you I'm just telling you
how do I do it I'm I'm so amazed that
you're so laid back and like you don't
give a
[__] talk to me what do you want me to
say why don't you care is it because you
hate
Seline what is it having to do with
cooking sir cuz she said to me in the DI
every time she tries to tell you
something bang you jump down her she
will come and attack me attack you yes
sir like saying that I'm me here for too
long it's time for me to go if you're
not prepared to change yeah I think
she's
right okay if it is time for me to go I
go that was easy
Martin absolutely gross that source is
Dreadful
p is raw soggy pile of dough they would
[__] kidnap me if I served that in
Jamaica right now how are the petties
and sauce is Dreadful I don't like it
myself it's like a gloop the sad news
about the Pate the past is undercooked
it's hideous hideous let me get rid of
these for you and this one is the jerk
chicken hot flashes is that the same
Source yes take that way please D take
this way you got it thank you look at my
it looks like a silicon implant
perfectly
formed guys do not put any more jerk
sauce on his plate he hates
it o nasty not an ounce of seasoning
there cold how's our signature dish
Bland as
[__] cold chicken disgusting over cooked
rice and when was that chicken cooked I
couldn't tell you to be honest with you
go and ask doctor this is dry as hell
wor it thank
you
when was the chicken made Dr what you
didn't like it no dry you know why jerk
chicken is dry in Jamaica it's supposed
to be dry he doesn't eat Jamaican food
every day I eat it every day so I don't
know what he knows of jerk chicken this
is our oxtail student lima beans
cartilage
everywhere what a mess
$20 how's the oxil sadly nothing's been
trimmed so it's full of that bland and
the temperature I mean everything across
the board here was sort of barely
lukewarm okay let me get rid of that for
you an embarrassment it sucks man like I
I've made points about this like
everything they said you've already said
before huh yeah I'm just glad that I was
right you know the right side exactly
okay doctor I would like a word with you
I'm not afraid of Chef Ramsey I'd like
to talk to you and K even if he had
horns I wouldn't be afraid of him okay
I'm I'm
embarrassed I walk in a dying room that
felt cold and just flat when the food
arrived
soulless everything was horrendous
barely
lukewarm dry and
tasteless it's an insult to
Jamaica the patties the actual pastry on
the side was
raw as for the jerk source
disgusting I'm going to say this um from
the get-go I always felt that everything
should be fresh cooked order you guys
come in the morning could you be quiet
he's
talking okay let's move on shall we I've
got bigger issues honestly hot
flashes isn't that a system of
menopause you can not necessarily not
necessary depends on how you perceive it
forget the strange name that's Dreadful
Jerk Chicken dry just a minute let me
set you
straight most Jerk Chicken in Jamaica
are dry as a matter of fact I let me
finish I feel that the jerk chicken that
we do are more moist than the one they
do in Jamaica now let me tell you
something also let me finish let me
finish my sentence
first mostly dry I can accept dry and
edible I
can't I'm ready for an argument cuz I am
not going to sit here and kiss your ass
for trying to tell me that is a Jamaican
jerk chicken you're trying to let you me
no no no I'm not trying to let you I
would walk into your hospital and
attempt to tell you your job I am
telling you I don't know what kind of
herb from Jamaica you've been smoking
but that is disgusting crap did you just
did you did you just pull it out of the
fridge yes chef what is that it's
chicken and why you cooking them in
advance cuz of space space for time just
touch that hard as a r it's how many
pors you got in there cooked ahead of
show me the tray PJ
please that's dve in the Nevada desert
these look like they were cooked
[Music]
yesterday I mean are they [__] solid
huh I
mean I mean I wouldn't hang out on a
Christmas tree that chicken it's already
cooked it's going to get cooked again
who the [__] would want to eat this and
he's absolutely right Le Kei so I'm
trying to go up to speed with the chefs
just feel that
there solid chicken that's like for the
chicken parm they don't make it to
order2 32 why
not we've always done it that way we
really didn't know it's a problem that's
just m insane this sucks despite a fast
start how's your meal we haven't had any
yet we're waiting and it's very long the
disorganized kitchen is now delivering
food at a snail's pace I'm waiting on a
cheese raviol it's getting hot just we
give it a second bro come on dude be
right there bro I'm waiting on 13 and 11
I've never seen such a dysfunctional
Kitchen in all my [__] life Chris
squashed down the corner the chicken
reheated all these plates have got chips
on them what's all those ticket on the
floor it's just Madness my absolute
Madness where's Lisa where's
Keith you like [__] serious
[Music]
people haven't gotten their meals in
over 45 minutes the kitchen is just a
whole mess and my mother and Keith were
nowhere to be
found is Mommy and Keith somewhere they
sit in the car for no reason Keith and
my mother are sitting out in the
driveway on a crazy crazy night I'm
starving we can't handle this we need
help well you know maybe they should
come and worry about the problems that
are really happening right now yeah like
how um that the kitchen's a disaster
chicken Palms pick it up my mother order
this or she she's going to sit in the
car and eat it is this normal when we
get busy I'm embarrassed
now why was this ordered under your name
oh it's mine you're going to eat it out
here what am I going to eat it with my
my fingers here that's what they that's
what you want e give me
Fork stuffed pork chop Prim Vera white
with pen while the two owners died in
the car where's my bus girl I got a far
Val here's your chicken and sausage I
have 21 and 22 Michael does his best to
round the staff and complete dinner
service spaghetti and
me's get out of here
boys okay I'm going to get straight to
the point you two you've been abusing
your
Restaurant Van gets angry Michael gets
frustrated Ricky gets upset the owners I
didn't see you get upset I saw you walk
outside with a coat and you were sa in
the car a it's a
joke ke help me I uh my passion is a
little uh uh you know
down if you got behind this bar and you
got on the floor and you did something
to show you care people see that
customers aren't going to care about
your business if you don't give a [__]
about it and the two of you said it on a
million occasions walking the place I
don't even give a [__] about about this
place anymore I hope it [__] Burns
well you know what that's what it's
doing burning right to the [__]
ground it's relaunch night at down City
and while Abby and Rico get the front of
the house ready for the most important
night in the restaurant's history we are
going to rock this town tonight let's go
let's go back in the kitchen then we're
going to go here table by table until we
have to do picks yes cheff James is
doing the same with the kitchen staff
every dish perfect every time folks how
are we doing tonight welcome welcome
welcome have you had a chance to look at
all the new and fun exciting menu items
that we have let's go guys yeah I want
to hear you tonight I want to hear you
too yes let's go only minutes into the
service a locally renowned food blogger
has arrived Stacy Place ripped apart her
last meal at the restaurant Abby
recognize her yeah you know how
important she is but Chef Ramsey
convinced her to give it another try she
has 10,000 followers she blogs tomorrow
we're 10,000 potential customers back up
I've tried everything everything on this
menu today so if you have any questions
you feel free to ask any favorites that
we should oh yeah definitely the goat
cheese truffle dip really stood out for
me well that sounds really good Jimmy
you and I we're going to be
communicating all night I need the app
for 37 17 and 35 all right right now in
the window I need that fishing chip I
need that slider slider's up Che a
reinvigorated Jimmy has the kitchen
moving in the right direction Camari
sliders Jimmy keep it going yeah F salad
on the Fly and the new menu is being
embraced by the
customers wow but just when it appears
as though it's going to be smooth
sailing I need a chowder a calamari a
slider Jimmy did you call a calamari for
table 30 I just did Abby and Jimmy
listen to me are having a communication
breakdown I need four soups and one Chow
up in the line please that's incorrect
uhoh Here We Go Again a repeat of last
night the kitchen's going down we're
[__] Jimmy [__] cuz I'm 3
yeah this is the golden
ticket this is it all right lead ticket
I need a trule dip truffle dip takes 6
minutes yes yes sir all right get it in
the oven Jimmy look at me we're falling
behind got to work
together come on guys there's nothing
coming out please let's get this food
out give me your time on the trle D
please Jes she's not vlogging now is she
what's she doing she's definitely
vlogging she's blogging live from the
table we've got bloggers live from their
table guys I need a travel dip up on the
line right now urgently please I was
horrified we slipping like the night
before they're blogging as we speak I
wanted to like just scream come on guys
I need some food on the line there's
nothing hitting the window come on guys
I need to see some food up on this line
it's taking too long literally my
kitchen going down in
flames listen Jimmy one minute Abigail
and there was literally nothing I could
do about it Abby Jimmy I need a
come on
[Music]
guys your boss represents the company if
you see a boss slacking off what's that
tell you I mean he doesn't even dress up
in a chef's jacket who am I busting my
ass for was seemingly the weight of the
world on his shoulders Frank is about to
face a busy night as word has leaked out
that Chef Ramsey is at dbby day welcome
to DAV the okay now have the uh Bill
chop okay all in but back in the kitchen
Frank come on it appears as though Frank
has given up before dinner has even
started Frank come on come on come on
come
on the only reason why I don't quit is
because I'm too proud let's go one
salmon one tag one sh freid enjoy your
dinner as orders continue to pile into
the kitchen I'm waiting on a duck and a
salmon I got the duck right here can I
call a table 20 please table 20 a
depressed Frank tries to get motivated
what's up on table 10 Z 38 PL three bags
yeah I'm [__] it up right now but
it's not long before the kitchen is
backed
up you they are coming out they are
coming out the kitchen is a little bit
behind I need two F chinny ballet on the
flight hey Anthony slow it the [__] down
what do you think I'm doing shut up I
know what you want my brother I hate his
attitude I hate work on him cuz like I
can't tell Frank anything without him
telling me to go [__] myself T dir 1
been waiting an hour please shut the
[__]
up talk to each other you guys say
nothing it's just like the blind leading
the blinds why I think Ramsey is great
because it's like he's the only one he's
going to listen to table 10 it's out
there if we list to him I'm waiting on
32 can't cook that fast I need every
next stop talking to me rush rush rush
what the [__] is it with the society I
need two bades all right I'm behind
ready yeah they're going to send this
back all right stop cooking another one
cuz they're going to send it
back this goes to Table 5 do it now fish
was bad I was like ah [__] it let it
roll I took a gamble I mean it doesn't
look pretty but if they like it they
like it if not I'm sorry this was really
dry sorry
great I salmon on the Fly table five to
drive what's
Phong what did I tell you Frank you knew
that was coming back why did you send it
they going to get a complaint either way
they're going to wait too long but
they're going to send it back I'd rather
they wait and have it perfect than wait
and send [__] to come
back sad is
[Music]
that when a chef doesn't care that means
the rest goes downhill rapidly and
that's exactly what's happening tonight
I think Frank is way too burnt out right
now it's more depressing than anything
unbelievable it's an hour and a half
into dinner service table 20 and table
three that's what I'm putting up and
food is slowly making its way out to the
diners it's gross but unfortunately it's
not worth the
wait Frank this is lukew yes son of a
[__] [__] getting your [__] lemon
juice [__] stupid chicken out of your
[__] [__] paron me oh not
what he says it's overdone shut the [__]
up this is the way it is go come back
with
it this is it this is the breaking point
of this restaurant right here food sucks
anyway and I'm putting up [__] [__]
Frank needs to make a commitment to
working hard and if you don't have that
passion you don't have it and you got to
get out of here any more [__] slips
coming in Frank we're screwed I'm not
[__] cooking I'm not doing it I'm
[__] I need a fishing chips a
shepherd's pie and a sliced steak yes
yes Mitch it appears as though Mitch and
the kitchen are now on the same page and
the cooks are beginning to fill the
orders Mitch which day when she say 40 H
I don't know I have to wait she comes
back oh Jesus but shiff Ramsey notices
another potential communication problem
don't you have a copy of the tickets no
I don't have an expediter needs the
control of the tickets wow we haven't
even got a decent POS system Jesus
Christ so there's the order I need that
now just get out yeah there's confusion
with the dupes all the time because it's
all handwritten it's so Antiquated it's
just it's ridiculous come on guys
take you I did but it's fine I don't
think so well the chefs rush to push
food out stop that was the French onion
soup little attention is being paid to
qual control just stop for two seconds
look we cannot serve that we cannot go
to this extent and try to start building
a reputation and serving that when
you're the expeditor you're the last
point of control right so your standards
are there their standards are there
you've got to start putting in some
structure come on
Mitch we're working on a chief right now
they're doing it now well get the [__]
out fish and chips
43 after a slow start fish and chips
food is now making its way out to the
diners everything's good okay and while
the new specials are making a good
impression it definitely tastes like an
actual Irish dish yeah the regular
menu it's like isn't impressing anyone
that's this is
gross my apologies okay h
that's supp medium well and that's
medium rare come on be medium I need
another Burger beat him well where's the
standard what Burger come on guys how
could you [__] up a hamburger I'm still
upset tomato forger medium yes
yes [__] come
here oh all of you come
here touch it it's [__]
raw did you check it no I didn't come
on Mario all I want is a
burger a [__]
Burger come on what the [__] is going on
Mitch I'm watching your mistakes see if
you can go outside and say hi to people
no I can't go out you're not helping any
you're not doing anything here so what
good are you yes 2 hours into dinner
service and the kitchen is beginning to
unravel it
sucks this is ice cold with Dish is that
too rare too rare after dish the penny
is raw coming
back a dear sorry just would you mind
just take that away for 2 seconds I'm so
sorry excuse me we got two seconds
morning what is
that let me just tell you something when
I was busting my chops earlier making it
for you I turn my back for 5 minutes and
you send that out chef chef come on guys
on the back of
115 customers in 2 and 1/2 hours
resolved to that Chef Ramsey was just
like to hell with all of you there's no
passion there's no care for any of the
food coming out all you [__] get paid
where's the wor on your faces if you're
my Brigade I would you fired you [__]
16 years ago you you you you you you and
[__]
you